the FBI is is now it says reviewing the
reviewing the justice Millette case
specifically reviewing the circumstances
that led to the cases the charges
against him being dropped they're not
calling it an investigation they're
calling it a review meanwhile Kim Fox
the state's attorney behind all of this
is standing by her decision though
admitting as I think I played for you
yesterday on the show admitting that she
thinks Smollett is guilty and that they
could have proved him guilty so she
thinks he's guilty could've proved him
guilty they let him go anyway but she
says well it's perfectly normal for
people who are charged with these kinds
of crimes just be let off the hook on
the promise of doing community service
or whatever now you know what here's the
thing about that she could be right for
all I know maybe it's true that people
who are charged with these kinds of
things very often or let off the hook or
maybe it's not true because they were
there actually there were leaked emails
from her office where she after she made
this claim she sent an email to her
staff saying hey guys can you pull up
examples of us actually letting people
off the hook with a community service
for filing false police reports we need
examples so she made that claim and now
she needs to go scramble and find
examples I don't think she's found one
yet so it's a little bit like it's a
little bit like when you're in an
argument with your wife and you're mad
at her and you say you say well you
always do this and then she says oh yeah
give me one example one time when I've
done this and you say I'll get back to
you on that so that's kind of what's
going on with her but but even if it's
true that these kinds of deals are often
made with people who file false police
reports well there's a couple of
differences though number one of course
in a normal situation of filing a false
police report it doesn't become a
national story so the difference is that
Jesse smollett not only filed the false
police report but he went in front of
the entire country and he tried to
foment more racial division for the sake
of his own advancement
and an let's let's not forget that he
was willing to let and he still is
willing to let innocent people take the
phone when he originally found out that
they had had arrested a couple of
suspects before he knew it was his
friends he said oh yeah must be then
because he thought it was too just
random white dudes and he was willing to
let them to let them go to jail on hate
crime charges so this is different for
that reason but there's another thing
too they could have made this exact same
deal and said fine we'll keep your bond
do a little community service we won't
go through the whole trial rigmarole but
what they could have and should have
done is said here's the condition you
have to go outside of that courthouse
get in front of the cameras and admit
what you did if you do that then we're
good in fact maybe we even give you your
bond back because it doesn't matter
because for someone like him for a
narcissistic liar who's doing this for
for fame and fortune the worst penalty
that you could give him is that in fact
that would be a lot worse than sending
him to jail for a couple of months or
whatever and letting him continue to
play the victim and play and pretend
that he's innocent so they could have
done the real scandal here the real
travesty is not just that they didn't go
through the trick with the trial it's
that they let him walk out of that
courtroom and stand on the courthouse
steps and play the victim and continue
to pretend that he's innocent that's
what the what the scandal is that's what
makes this so outrageous because they
could have easily said to him listen
we've got you we've got you on this you
know that we've got you we've got all
the evidence if this goes to trial
you're screwed and we're gonna throw the
book at you we're gonna send you to jail
for years we're gonna find you as much
as we possibly can
we're gonna find even more crimes to
charge you with unless you walk out
there and admit what you did they could
have done that and they didn't and
that's the the travesty here okay I want
to switch it gears here early in the
show I want to play a clip for you and I
want to do it close to the begin
of the of the show because it's
important that you see it and before I
play it
let me read first from a report in
LifeSite News it says an 85 year old
pro-life advocate was brutally assaulted
outside a Planned Parenthood facility in
San Francisco last Thursday the
pro-lifer was taking part in a peaceful
40 Days for Life campaign when the
perpetrator stole the victims banner and
viciously beat him the same assailant
had attacked the the victim and another
man just two days prior the elderly man
tried to stop the theft of the banner by
putting his his the the stick holding
the banner into the spokes of the
bicycle you'll see this in a second but
it's important this just gives a little
bit of a context and then the
perpetrator shoves the man to the ground
so we'll see all of that but the point
is what you're about to witness here the
context is that this guy stole a
pro-life banner property that didn't
belong to him the elderly man 85 years
old goes and tries to retrieve his
property and then this is what happens
[Music]
now I want you to understand that what
you just saw there is not unusual it is
not an exception to the rule
violent assaults against pro-life
demonstrators are quite common and let's
let's run through I'm gonna play a bunch
now let's just go down memory lane here
because as I said it's it's very common
for pro-abortion extremists to assault
pro-life demonstrators such as if you
were if you remember this one
[Applause]
Hey
destruction of private property yes a
lot he gets raped by somebody and
they're like I can the 16 year old and I
can't have this baby I think you should
keep it it's a baby if someone is raped
and she gave birth and she decided to
kill her three-year-old child how about
this and then there's this
[Music]
and I could go on for three or four
hours playing clips like that because
they're all over YouTube I mean all you
have to do is just go on YouTube and
type in pro-life or assaulted and you'll
get hundreds of hits on that so you get
the idea the point is that pro-abortion
extremists are often violent and
unhinged this should not be a surprise
considering what they support and even
when they're not being violent they will
very often verbally assault pro-lifers
go stand outside of an abortion clinic
sometime if you don't believe me stand
with the people who are holding vigils
trying to counsel women and see the
treatment that they endure from
passers-by from clinic staff from from
everybody you may actually be shocked by
it if you believe and listen to the
media I don't know why you would at this
point but if you do you may be under the
impression that protestors the pro-life
protesters are the ones who are standing
outside of clinics all the time
shouting you know shouting at the women
going in and heckling and harassing no
that's that's not what happens it's the
other way around it's they stand there
praying that's the way that pro-life
demonstrations usually go most people
are silent and they're simply praying
and at a clinic you'll most people will
be silent except for a sidewalk counsel
or counselor who will try to approach
women who are going into the clinic
approach them not to yell at them or
insult them or anything like that but
simply to inform them about the other
options they have available because the
clinic will not do that the clinic will
not tell women that they have other
options and in the midst of that what
will happen is those pro-lifers who are
being peaceful and mostly silent will be
harassed or assaulted and it's quite
common one of the weirdest such cases
was a couple of years ago when a what
really appears to be a demonically
possessed abortion doctor came out to
confront a pro-lifer and it was like it
was base
sickly is seen from The Exorcist watch
this friends free sir you got repent sir
you got a repent sir for murdering
babies why because it's a sin before God
why well stinky breath
yeah that's pretty it's pretty evil you
sir yeah yeah and I hope and pray that
you yeah well that's what you do to
babies oh yeah I love it you love it oh
yeah I do okay I hope that you come to
Christ sir oh I'd ever go to Christ I
hope that you come to Christ no no I
don't go to Christ yeah you I don't
listen to crimes you will have a
darkened heart so I do have a heart
doctor
yeah you have a darkened I do I do very
very much and you will stand before God
and judgment every day you will stand
before God and judge yes I will every
day all the babies I love it yeah keep
tearing a baby yeah I will you turn the
baby I will keep keep tearing the babies
apart yes sir the babies their blood
screams from the ground now I'm not
gonna claim okay that you can't find
examples of pro-life demonstrators
acting inappropriately you certainly can
but there is really no comparison the
violence and harassment almost always
comes from the other side almost always
and you're not gonna see this in the
media but that is the reality and as I
said it's not surprising because they
are defending violence they are
defending the slaughter of hundreds of
thousands of innocent children so
obviously they're not going to have any
problem with stealing a sign or
assaulting an 85 year old man that's
pittance compared to to what they're
defending so that that that shouldn't
surprise us too much but also the other
thing about this dynamic between pro
lifers and pro-abortion people when
you've got pro-life demonstrators on one
side and pro-abortion people on the
other remember that the pro-abortion
people are by definition inherently
selfish okay so it's all about them
personally when they are protesting or
demonstrating in favor of abortion
they're doing it because it's something
that they want for themselves they want
to have this privilege if we can call it
that I certainly won't call it a right
to kill babies because it will make
their life easier and that's why they
get emotional okay so this is not
righteous anger on behalf of the
oppressed no this is the anger of a
selfish deluded person who feels like
their own convenience
is is going to be intruded upon and for
the men who act this way they want
abortion to be legal so that they can
use women as objects and they never have
to worry about the responsibilities that
may come from that on the other hand and
this you know I think I said this around
the time of the March for life this is
what makes something like the March for
Life such a beautiful and inspiring
event is that pro-lifers whether you
agree with them or not what you cannot
deny is that these are selfless people
they're not doing it for themselves you
don't go and stand outside of an
abortion clinic for your own sake you
don't you don't gain anything from that
you don't go to the March for Life and
take a bus and go all the way there in
January when it's freezing cold it's
stand outside in the cold for four hours
for yourself you know there's nothing
that you gained from that the people who
are involved in the pro-life cause
contrary to the ones who are
pro-abortion the ones who are pro-life
they are in it to protect those who
cannot protect themselves they are
focused outwardly to the other to the
person who cannot speak for themselves
whereas for pro Borgia people it's all
it's all about me me me that is the
crucial difference between the two and
that explains I think they're different
shall we say strategies and getting
their message across all right I want to
for a moment revisit this story about
cardi B you may remember from yesterday
she's the famous female rapper
admitted in an Instagram video that she
used to drug and rob men she lured them
back to her hotel after after a night of
stripping she would have them come back
to this is what she admitted to having
to come back to the hotel and she would
drug and Rob them
she said all this in a video that she
posted online for some reason a couple
of years ago and yesterday she posted a
barely coherent statement defending
herself explaining that she had no
choice but to drug and rob men and we
all need to stop criticizing her because
she's living her truth and she's being
herself and she's being honest and this
is what she needed to do a couple of
follow up points about this the the
incomparable idiots over at Vox are
perfectly willing to buy this excuse an
article on Vox
that was supposed to published I think
last night explains that cardi B will
not be hurt by this scandal and really
she shouldn't be and the article says
this for one thing and the the author of
the articles trying to draw a
distinction between cardi B and someone
like Bill Cosby or are Kelly she says
for one thing that's the there's the
difference in degree between what cardi
says she did and what Cosby and Kelly's
accusers say they did Cosby and Kelly
have been accused of repeatedly over a
period of decades using the power they
accumulated as celebrities to drug and
rape women in Cosby's case and to rape
and abuse women and young girls in
Kelly's case cardi says that she drugged
and robbed men before she became rich in
powerful celebrity in order to survive
Cosby and Kelly have been accused of
repeated violent and sadistic abuses of
power over decades cardi has admitted to
a crime of survival a crime of survival
no a crime of survival is when you're
literally starving to death and so you
steal a loaf of bread from the
supermarket so you don't die that's a
crime of survival cardi B was a stripper
and she made plenty of cash in that
profession so so what are we saying she
would have starved to death had she not
had this side gig of drugging and
robbing men by the
I did look this up because I figured
that somewhere she probably has bragged
about how much money she actually made
as a stripper and sure enough I found
this in Yahoo news from just a couple of
months ago
it says the Grammy nominated artist
started dancing at 18 and while she
admits her first time was embarrassing
the checks helped her get over that
feeling quickly she says I was seeing
money that I feel like I would have
never seen ever at first I started off
making 2 or $300 sometimes not making
money at all because you've got to pay
your house fee and my house fees were
very expensive but after I got good
there were nights where I would leave
with 2,000 or 3,000 dollars when I was
21 I had to twenty thousand dollars
saved up when I was 22 I already had
$35,000 saved up in singles so she
couldn't survive on three grand a night
well then how am I still alive how are
you still breathing if three thousand
dollars a night isn't enough to get you
by and so you have to drug and rob
people very few people on earth make
more than three thousand dollars a day
so we should all be dead according to
cardi B and Vox but cardi B she just
couldn't make it work you know with her
budget she had no choice if instead of
pretending to buy that excuse as some
people are why don't you just come out
and say she's a woman and her victims
were men so it's okay because that's
what you really mean that's obviously
what you actually mean so why don't you
come out and say we all know this what
you're saying the people that are
defending cardi B it's because she's a
woman and and so admit it no the real
difference between cardi B and Bill
Cosby and r kelly is that she's a woman
and they're men I forgot to mention
another video of cardi B surfaced this
one of her bragging about getting guys
drunk and then tricking them into
sleeping with transsexuals why would she
do that I don't know there's not a lot
of context to it but that's what she
says
and I mean we know there are double
standards with the way that women are
sometimes treated with these things but
this is beyond the pale this woman is a
vile crook who should be in prison it's
just a confessing she's confessing to
one violent crime after another this
woman should have 60 years in prison by
now but there's one other thing I wanted
to say about this as I was thinking
about it
cardi B's excuses that she not only was
doing what she what she had to do to
survive but also that she's she's living
her truth right she's she's being real
she's being honest she's being herself
whatever and I'm kind of glad she went
in that direction with her excuse for
this behavior because it helps to expose
just how vacuous and absurd the whole
hey I'm just being me thing really is
people have used it very often
especially these days as an excuse to
behave like pigs and this is just one of
the more extreme examples where people
say I'm being me this is my truth on
being real well okay then
but if this is you and you're being real
then that just means that you're a
horrible person the fact that you're
being yourself and being real is not an
excuse to be horrible if your self is
horrible
then you need to change yourself because
that's bad so it reminds me of that you
know that stupid slogan that you see
sometimes floating around online and
memes and so forth that goes like if you
can't handle me at my worst then you
don't deserve me at my best
it's that it's a similar kind of
attitude that people have where a person
takes ownership takes prideful ownership
of their worst behavior and says
basically everyone has to deal with it
because this is just me being me and I'm
being myself but no you see if I can't
handle you at your worst that's because
you're a bad person and you're miserable
to be around and that's why no one
likes you it's not because they're
haters or they're jealous or they're
trying to stifle you no it's simply
because you're an abysmal insufferable
excruciating human being that's what it
is
and I shouldn't have to tolerate your
awfulness as some sort of price of
admission so that I can experience your
best because I got to tell you something
your best isn't that great either but
this is the the attitude that we
encourage in kids these days especially
we say be who you are
and if people don't like it it's it's
their fault it's their problem no it's
it's probably your fault if you find
that everyone around you always turns
out to be a hater and you're constantly
in conflict with everyone and everyone
is out to get you all the time and you
can't maintain friendships of relations
with relationships with anyone then look
at the common denominator it's time for
an epiphany where you go oh wait every
everyone around me hates me because I'm
terrible that's why okay you know what a
lot of this is it's it's it's
shamelessness disguised as honesty
people think it's okay these days to be
terrible if they're honest about it and
if they're being real and so they can
simply admit and that's what cardi B is
doing she said yeah I drugged and robbed
man but I'm being real about it being
honest with you no that's not that's not
really honesty that's shamelessness and
there's a difference now honesty is when
you admit to being terrible and doing
awful things and you're remorseful about
it and ashamed okay well that is really
brave and bold honesty I'll give you
that but if you're taking these terrible
things about yourself and you're
parading them in front of the world and
saying hey everyone look at me
that is shamelessness and as I said
there's a difference and it's not good
all right let's
well I had okay I gotta I can't I can't
move on to the inbox before I play I
played a lot of clips but I got to play
this one too because this one I found on
Twitter and it's maybe the most
relatable thing you've ever seen watch
this
good morning TPS students it is testing
week and it's time to slay all day they
won't be on fleek and get that Gucci
breakfast goals say bye Felicia to that
testing stress weather's gonna be turned
right Chris yes Toledo weather gonna be
the lit during testing week a hundo pee
chance of success you've got this kids
Steve how about that traffic are we look
at okay better than oh we're talking
turn follow won't be an issue
no traffic problems around any TPS
schools to keep you from taking those
tests that really does as a Christian I
can say that really reminds me of every
single youth pastor I've ever met in my
life
it's basically exactly like that and we
wonder why we can't get young kids to go
to church alright let's go to the inbox
you can email the show Matt wall show at
gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
this is from Brandon says hey Matt love
your show I started listening to your
podcast about a month ago and now I
actually enjoy my hour-long commute to
work every morning I noticed you've
mentioned a few times now that beans
don't belong in chili I don't think I've
ever had chili without beans as I feel
it would be empty without it have I been
wrong my whole life anyway I appreciate
what you do gods be yes Brandon you have
been I regret to inform you wrong your
whole life the International chili
society has officially defined what a
chili is and frankly it's a sign of our
crumbling education system that you
Brandon have apparently never read the
bylaws of the International chili
society but let me read for you
commandment number one on there a rule
sheet about what constitutes a chili it
says true chili is defined by the
International chili society as any kind
of meat or combination of meats cooked
with chili peppers various other spices
and other ingredients
with the exception of items such as
beans or spaghetti which are strictly
forbidden why are they forbidden because
they are meaningless filler beans and
chili is like when people put walnuts in
brownies it's not like it's bad
necessarily but there's no point to it
it's if you're distracting from the main
event if I'm eating if I'm eating a
brownie it's because I want the
chocolate so why are you putting these
little gaps of non chocolate into my
brownie what is the point of this in
fact if I'm at someone's house and they
serve me brownies with walnuts I will
say exactly this to them and I'll throw
it in their face which is I think the
only reasonable response and it's the
same thing with chili that the main
event is the meat and everything that is
not meat or that does not accentuate the
meat like the spices do is pointless why
is it there all right from mark it says
what talking about the this is referring
to the New York Times article we
mentioned on the show yesterday that was
attempting unsuccessfully to disprove
God says when the professor made the
argument regarding the problem of evil
he said natural evils are wrong while
you made a good argument regarding that
men are the cause because our sin
wrecked the world there's another
argument that's missing another answer
is that since men are sinful any
suffering they experience is just we
don't deserve life pleasure comfort or
anything good that God has given us that
all comes from His grace the question
should be why do bad things happen to
people the real question is since man is
so evil why does anything good happen to
people at all well the answer to that is
God's grace also you mentioned that
God's omniscience and his omnipotence
are contradictory
well I mention I don't think they're
contradictory I'm saying that that is a
that's a more compelling atheist
argument but I explained how it's not
actually true you gave the the God
exists in a in a bee theory of time
while that argument works for those that
don't subscribe to the bee theory of
time and other answer is that there is
no logical reason for these two to
contradict just because I know what I
would do in a certain situation doesn't
mean I lack in power to do those things
for example I know that I'm going to eat
the bag of
in front of me does my knowledge of that
take away from my power or ability to do
those things absolutely not it doesn't
really make sense mark I know your your
answer to the problem of evil I I don't
think that's going to be a successful
answer when you're talking to someone
who's secular atheist agnostic because
what you're trying to argue is that well
I mean just take any horrible thing you
can think of and then you're saying well
that person deserve that thing so I mean
fill in the blank think of the most
horrible thing that could have happened
to a person a child and then you're
saying well yeah but are they deserved
it really because they're sinful I don't
think that's the I don't think that's a
successful answer and I certainly don't
think it's going to be a convincing
answer to an atheist I think if they
hear that they're gonna just run away
screaming and saying you're crazy
that's insane yeah you try to tell me I
a child with brain cancer as well he
deserves it no that's not no child does
not deserve cancer I will say that
unequivocally but theologically speaking
as I said you know when we're trying to
answer the question of these so-called
natural evils natural suffering as
opposed to the kinds of suffering that
we can explain through freewill which is
a little bit easier to explain somebody
victimizes another person will that
happen because that bad person chose to
do it right natural evil is a little bit
more difficult we can't explain that
without getting into some theology there
is obviously no way around that and so
the theology there is that man fell out
of harmony with nature and with himself
through sin and so I think that's our
that's our answer we can kind of leave
it there from Jeff it says Matt who
would win in a fight the Ninja Turtles
are Power Rangers I guess I would give
it to the Power Rangers because they can
make that Megazord thing right and you
know just stomp on the Ninja Turtles but
great question thank you for that from
Timothy says hi Matt loved the show I've
heard you briefly mentioned the issue of
the Order of the Gospels before could
you explain that which gospel was
written first and how do we know and
when
like when were the Gospels all written
yeah I think we've talked about this
before I we don't know exactly when the
Gospels were written or or in what order
but this is something biblical scholars
have been studying and debating for a
long time different theories have
emerged and as you can imagine there are
you know atheists and secular scholars
are going to have slightly different
answers from Christian scholars so just
a quick overview based on my reading
everyone agrees that John was written
last you even go back to the church
fathers they also there's basically
universal agreement throughout history
on that point so we can be pretty sure
about that
the most prominent theory today is that
mark was written first and there are a
few reasons a few reasons to think that
but the primary reason is that almost
all of mark the text of mark Oh
almost all of it is contained in Matthew
and then to a lesser extent Luke so it's
clear and sometimes verbatim you've got
these verbatim passages between three
Gospels that's why they're called the
Synoptics so it's clear that somebody
went first and used the others as a
source we know that it wouldn't really
make sense if Matthew in first and then
Mark came along and made a gospel out of
Matthew because mark is so much shorter
than Matthew and Mark leaves out some
really important things like the virgin
birth which is an in mark so it wouldn't
make sense if Mark was second and he
made a gospel based on Matthew and all
he did then was was just he took some of
it and cut out some really important
parts and then made his own gospel out
of it in that case Mark would just be an
abridgment of Matthew and there's almost
no reason for it to be in the Bible in
that case but if it came first well then
it's sort of the one of the original
source documents and Matthew and Luke
used it and then added details fleshed
it out based on their own sources and
for Matthew his own eyewitness
experience so that to me
mix makes a lot of sense it just makes a
lot more sense than the idea that Mark
wrote some sort of abridgement of
Matthew
as for when they were written well
secular scholars will push all the
Gospels after the year 70 AD because
that's when the Temple in Jerusalem was
destroyed which is mentioned in the
Gospels and so they'll say well it must
obviously these things were written
after that happened because they mention
it
whereas Christians will say well no it
was a prophecy so it happened before so
I think we you know they were written at
least John all of the Gospels except for
John written before 70 but not too much
before 70 because Paul was writing up
until the mid-60s there about and in his
letters he never mentions the Gospels
explicitly the written Gospels doesn't
cite them rarely mentions any of the
stories they contain and it seems
inconceivable to me that if the Gospels
existed when Paul was writing that he
would not have frequently cited them
just like modern-day missionaries you
know they're not going to go around and
never mention the Gospels they're gonna
mention them frequently right so Paul
doesn't mention them at all I think it's
because they didn't exist yet they
hadn't been written and so Matthew was
probably written sometime in the mid
sixties then Luke and then or you know
mark Matthew Luke and then John all
right finally this says this is from
Matt says Matt loved the show because I
agree with just about everything you say
but mostly because you have the best
first name ever likewise there was a lot
of talk about the new movie about
abortion unplanned being rated R by the
MPAA because it shows abortion related
content because the movie is rated R a
person under the age of 17 needs to have
a parent or adult accompany them in
order to watch a movie about abortion
but in the height of all irony's
pro-abortion activists in many states
are pushing to remove parental consent
laws relative to abortion
claiming that many teens should be able
to decide for themselves whether to
slaughter their unborn baby
thus the left apparently believes that
although a girl under the age of 17 is
too young to be able to watch a movie
about abortion that same girls
apparently mature enough to actually
have an abortion without her parent's
knowledge or consent that begs the
question is the reason why unplanned is
rated R because the content is too
mature for teen audiences or because the
left wants to keep the movies message
away from as many teens as possible the
question
answers itself yes it does answer itself
but thank you for bringing that point up
because it is as you say completely
absurd we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening everybody
god speed
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show the left's worst week ever
concludes with them using the only
weapon left at their disposal calling
conservatives bigots when the left calls
you're racist you know you've won the
argument check it out at daily wire calm